just when you thought the political
exploitation of the unspeakable tragedy
in texas could not get any more shameful
beto o'rourke decided to crash a somber
news conference by state officials in
the small town in which the tragedy took
place
to turn the public mourning into a petty
campaign stunt in his failing bid for
governor
excuse me
excuse me
excuse me
i can't believe you're a sick son of a
[ __ ] that would come to a deal like
this to make a political issue
is this what unsatisfied political
ambition does to a man
is this how hollow and inhuman
it makes you this man beto o'rourke
travels to a community reeling from
unspeakable horror
and hijacks their mourning their
assembly to learn the facts of what
happened
into a cheap campaign stunt so that he
could yell this is on you into the face
of his political opponent did he explain
how
it was on him how the shooting was greg
abbott's fault no did he explain what
something he would have done instead do
something do something does he say
what's something that is no and that's
not even the worst part did beto help
anyone in the room
did he comfort anyone in the room
did he ever consider even for one second
the victims and their families and the
community and their wishes did it ever
occur to him that maybe the families in
the local community didn't want to have
their grieving hijacked and turned into
a campaign stunt for a desperate
politician do any of these people have
even one scintilla of shame
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
nola show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from steve robson
who says me circa 2000 there's a small
powerful rich cabal of people that rule
the world and make all the decisions for
us
them circa 2000 steve that's a crazy
conspiracy theory and you sound like a
crazy person
me circa 2022 there is a small powerful
rich cabal of people that rule the world
and make all the decisions for us then
circa 2022 a new study from the fish and
wildlife bureau suggests that they have
seen a recent spike in homosexual frog
activity this is a very good point if
they don't want us to believe in crazy
conspiracy theories probably a good idea
for them not to
keep conspiring probably a good idea for
them not to show up to the world
economic forum and have klaus schwab the
head of it say via here we are building
the future the future won't just happen
we are building it we will conclude
together we will cooperate so if they
don't if they don't want us to think
they're conspiring they should probably
stop conspiring when you want to protect
not just your political community but
your home you got to check out ring
right now go to ring.com
knowles the summer is coming up summer
is always extremely busy everyone's away
traveling on vacation
i'm going to be away from home for quite
a bit but i can rest easy because of
ring that's right the protection
afforded by ring alarm is absolutely
magnificent now you might be thinking
ring ring you're talking about that
video doorbell company they've got an
alarm well yes they do they've got the
great video doorbell it's super cool see
and speak to whoever's at your door
wherever you are in the world they've
got the fabulous alarm
and now they've got the ring alarm pro
which cnet calls a giant leap for home
security so with the ring alarm you get
to protect your your windows your doors
from freeze fire flood bad guys
everything that's your physical home
well with ring alarm pro you protect
your digital home as well your wi-fi
your data we live so much of our lives
online well this summer you can protect
all of it with rings award winning alarm
go pro be a pro just like me go to
ring.com
knowlescanawles that is ring.com
knowles
everybody
is making
the tragedy in texas
about themselves and not everybody
that's not fair there are some people
who are being respectful
there are a lot of people in public life
disproportionately on the left just call
it like we see it who are making this
about them
and their interests and their agenda
and their pet projects
most notably yesterday barack obama
barack obama usually can read the room
he's a radical guy and he's he was a
terrible president and he's really bad
for america but usually he's at least a
fairly able politician who can take the
temperature of what's going on and and
calibrate his speech accordingly but the
guy was absolutely tone deaf yesterday
when he tweeted out
this is so bizarre i still don't quite
understand the thought process he says
as we grieve the children of uvalde
today we should take time to recognize
that two years have passed since the
murder of george floyd under the knee of
a police officer
his killing stays with us all to this
day especially those who loved him in
the aftermath of his murder a new
generation of activists rose up to
channel their anguish into organized
action launching a movement to raise
awareness of systemic racism and the
need for criminal justice and police
reform inspired by these young leaders
mbk alliance launched a reimagining
police pledge for mayors and cities
ready to take action if you're wondering
how you can help make things a little
better today here are some ways to get
involved and then he posts a picture of
trayvon martin
so it's not he
he says hey we're all thinking about
texas today but don't think about my
thing instead
hey we're all listen i know that this is
what everyone's talking about because of
how horrific it is but that's not
totally convenient for me so think about
george floyd
sorry never mind george floyd trayvon
martin actually sorry never mind just do
whatever i want me me me me
what what is he saying
who
does does barack obama really believe
that we have not talked enough about
george floyd
we
we spent two years talking about george
floyd
we spent two years largely hearing a
completely misrepresented take on what
happened to george floyd and who george
floyd was and having much of the real
story suppressed by the media and then
having that fake story be the impetus
for eight months of terrorism throughout
the united states from coast to coast
where blm activists mostly peaceful
mostly peacefully burned the country
down and burned multiple cities and then
high-ranking democrat officials
not only encouraged them to do this but
actually funded them bailed them out of
jail like kamala harris
but we haven't talked about him enough
and then somehow it's about trayvon
martin trayvon martin
who was killed in an altercation with
george zimmerman who's a hispanic guy
that the media lied and said was white
because they wanted to turn it into a
racial issue years ago and they said
that trayvon martin was just innocently
going to buy skittles and there was no
altercation then the evidence of
george zimmerman been being beaten up to
a pulp contradicted a lot of that and
then that was a media circus for years
that led to riots and led to all sorts
of mayhem throughout the country and
then barack obama decided to pour fuel
on the fire by saying trayvon martin
looks like my son would have looked if i
had a son he would look like trayvon
martin just to pour fuel on that fire
not for trayvon martin not for
george floyd
certainly he's not showing any care
whatsoever for this community in texas
it's just about him right it's just
about him and any way that he can score
a nice little political point that's
what he's going to do
whoopi goldberg is is expressing the the
other view
so
you've got on the one hand
some activists who are exploiting the
tragedy to push their own
almost entirely disconnected political
agenda then the the other prominent
reaction you're seeing
is is just anger directed at
conservatives anger directed at the
right but it's very vague anger there
aren't a lot of specifics here it's
anger at people who are offering
thoughts and prayers and they say how
dare you offer your thoughts and prayers
why won't you do something
what
are we doing
so that's the question
what are we doing because we're we're
why are we always at square one with
this and i swear to god if i see another
republican senator talk about their
heart being broken i'ma go punch
somebody and kind of thoughts i can't
take it and their thoughts and prayers
if your thoughts and prayers are really
with everybody you'd have done something
by now
it's not like anybody's not trying to
make this happen what the hell is going
on
you'd have done something you're you're
this is what beta orc was saying this is
on you this is on you greg abbott you
you caused this you do something do
something
what do you propose we do
you notice beto o'rourke isn't making a
whole lot of concrete proposals because
he doesn't care at all he's just he
thinks that he's going to look good on
the cover of the newspaper yelling and
screaming and if it if it disturbs the
people of this traumatized community and
if it interrupts their grief and then he
just walks out of there and moves on to
the next campaign event so what he got
he got a really good picture he thinks i
don't think it looks good at all but he
thinks he got a really good picture in
the newspaper and on cnn whoopi goldberg
deuce do something i'm going to punch
someone in the face if i hear thoughts
and prayers do something what do you
want to do
what do you propose we do
i told you yesterday on the show i have
no interest in debunking and owning the
the
political commentary of the gun control
of the talking points of the boom boom
more guns less crime i have no interest
in doing any of that i i think it's a
i don't think that's the appropriate
response in the immediate aftermath of
of a really unspeakable tragedy
but but i do have to ask all of these
people who are demagoguing the issue
what do you propose
name me one made me one i was even
trying to think what could the proposals
be there have been a ton of gun control
proposals in the last 20 years
aimed at reducing mass shootings marco
rubio pointed out some years ago now
this was in 2015. he said none of the
major shootings that have occurred in
this country over the last few months or
years that have outraged us would gun
laws have prevented them
this was an audacious outrageous claim
at the time
and then it was fact checked by the
washington post that is liberal and
outlet as there can be
and the washington post admitted he's
right
the washington post admitted there is
certainly a depressing chronicle of
death and tragedy but rubio's statement
stands up to scrutiny
stands up to scrutiny so
none of those
major laws that were proposed for gun
control would have stopped
the shooting
now maybe some people say okay ban
ar-15s
the way this shooting went down he could
have used a handgun this was not long
range high precision distance
a distance type of attack this was very
close up a handgun would have done the
same thing
so are you so now are we saying ban the
handguns well you've got a
constitutional problem there but frankly
even if you ban the handguns is there
any evidence that that's going to reduce
rates of murder that's not what happened
in the uk in the uk in 96 or 97 there
was an attack on an elementary school in
the uk so they banned handguns
and not only did the murder rate not go
down it actually went up it almost
doubled so okay that's probably not
going to work and then you're running up
against
in any case the constitutional problem
we have a second amendment that was
inherited
even before the
beginning of our our country formally
under the constitution we inherited that
right from the english so what are you
going to do you're going to repeal the
second amendment
good luck is there any political desire
for that no is it politically possible
no so then what do you want to do what
are you proposing i'm not i'm not even
saying i oppose all of these i do i
don't think that we should upend all of
our traditional civil rights but but
even if even if i were going to go with
you what what is the concrete thing when
you're yelling and screaming and saying
this is your fault and making a big
spectacle of yourself and interrupting
people's grief and standing on your high
horse and trying to express sympathetic
fury and outrage
what's your plan you don't have any plan
so all you're doing is demagoguing and
getting some nice pretty pictures in the
newspaper and then doing not you're
doing less than nothing
it's it's it's much worse than nothing
now when you want to
uh protect your home when you want to
protect your family strongly recommend
you check out american home shield right
now go to ahs.com
knowles do you want peace of mind and to
stay on a budget right now with record
high inflation and a really bad economy
you're probably going to want to protect
yourself from unexpected expenses that's
why you've got to check out american
home shield i love american home shield
you know your budget your time and your
sanity are all covered when you have got
american home shield you choose a plan
from them you keep your budget goals in
check for 2022 they've got a choice of
three great plans to help cover the cost
of repair or replacement on parts of
major home systems and appliances no
matter the age if american home shield
cannot repair the covered item they will
replace it american home shield members
get more more coverage options fewer
exclusions we're talking hvac systems
and plumbing to kitchen appliances their
plans help to protect parts of up to 23
essential home systems and appliances
electronics coverage is available for an
unlimited number of eligible items we're
talking smart watches flat screen tvs
and more roof leak repair pool and spa
coverage they've got everything okay
plus they are offering an exclusive 50
off for listeners of the michael knowles
show do it i have
struggled with home repairs before no
longer my friends thanks to american
home shield keep your home up and
running your budget on track with
american home shield get fifty dollars
off their most comprehensive plans ever
ahs dot com slash knowles save 50 bucks
that's ahs.com slash knowles for 50 off
any plan american home shield be sure
with the shield service please
limitations and exclusions apply see
plan for details
all of the demagoguery that we are
seeing right now
on the the shooting in texas
the the practical effect of it is going
to be nothing because the the people who
are really demagoguing the issue don't
have any concrete proposals they know
that the proposals that they've made in
years past through the same old
proposals they don't stand up to
scrutiny they don't even stand up to
scrutiny on the left that's why they're
not going to pass a law because
there's no political support for it all
it runs up against constitutional
problems
and
there's no evidence that it would solve
any of these problems
so what do you do then
well you use it as an opportunity to
push your own political agenda a
separate political agenda that's what's
really happening that's what obama's
doing beto o'rourke is too stupid he
he's just as classless as the rest of
them but he's too stupid to realize that
his strategy is not helping him
politically barack obama is slightly
more politically sophisticated
joe biden even is more politically
sophisticated so biden's doing the same
thing
that obama is doing joe biden is making
this about george floyd all
the same sort of shameless posturing as
we've seen all too often
public trust is frayed and broken
and that undermines public safety
the families here today
and across the country have had to ask
why this nation
why so many black americans wake up
knowing they could lose their life and
of course just living their life today
simply jogging shopping sleeping at home
whether they made headlines or not lost
souls gone too soon
members of congress including many here
today like senator cory booker and
congressman karen bass
alongside members of the congressional
black caucus house and senate judiciary
committees
spent countless hours on the george
floyd justin policing act
to find a better answer to that question
i sincerely thank you all for your
tireless efforts
so hold on you're
you're insinuating that the grief from
this tragedy reminds us just like obama
did it reminds us of george floyd and it
reminds us that let me check these notes
black people lose their lives at any
moment there are there is this epidemic
around the country they could be jogging
they could be sleeping at home and
they're all just getting gunned down and
killed right
does that happen i don't think that's
happening
i don't think any of the statistics back
that up whatsoever
and i i don't i don't even think that
the people believe this is happening i'm
not even convinced that your guys
believe this is happening joe
which is why you couldn't get the act
through it sounds there like he's
signing some
some piece of legislation some bill into
law right but that's not true he calls
it the george floyd justice and policing
act the george floyd justice and
policing act failed he has complete
control of the government and it failed
he couldn't get the votes for it
so instead what biden's doing here is
signing an executive order an executive
order that will do pretty much nothing
the executive order only applies at the
federal level and it changes some some
rules about
policing but
as we've seen over the past two years
people don't want weaker policing people
want much stronger policing
people don't want crime throughout their
communities they don't want their
communities to be burned down they want
people to be tougher on crime they want
our society to treat criminals more
harshly not continue to let them off the
hook so there's no political support for
this whatsoever
so all it is is posturing all we're all
we're seeing
especially from the democrats
is
vague
insinuations
that the other guys are bad and they're
really good and they're going to do
something and it's going to be and it's
important to do something rather than
nothing but what that something is they
just can't say because they've got
nothing they're not offering anything
so he just gets up there
and
regurgitates his word salad
of
vague emotional appeals and then signs a
completely toothless executive order and
then everybody moves on
because of
there's racism
racist the other guys are racist they're
bad they're they're they're the bad guys
who want bad things to happen and we're
the good guys and we want to do
something so that the good things happen
but what we do it's not we're not going
to actually do anything in particular
but we're
that's that's what we're in that's what
we're for we support that in theory
speaking of racism the united speaking
of racism and doing nothing the united
nations
is complaining now that coverage of the
impending monkey pox pandemic
is homophobic and racist
the un's aids agency unaids announced
that the reporting on the monkey box
virus is irresponsible and it's
undermining the response to the outbreak
and it's racist and homophobic according
to unaids deputy executive director
matthew kavanagh
says stigma and blame undermine trust
and capacity to respond effectively
during outbreaks like this one
experience shows that stigmatizing
rhetoric can quickly disable
evidence-based response by stoking
cycles of fear driving people away from
health services impeding efforts to
identify cases and encouraging
ineffective punitive measures
of course that is that is not the case
what he's saying is don't tell the truth
about this virus because
that if you tell the truth about this
virus people will be discouraged from
going to gay orgies because the virus is
largely spreading among gay men and not
even just any old gay men we're talking
about gay men who go and stup dozens of
people at bath houses and orgies that's
where the public health officials
believe this began at a gay fetish party
where everyone was shipping each other
and at a gay bath house in spain
but but the un doesn't want you to know
that
but shouldn't they if you're a gay guy
who
for whatever reason you're going down
you've gone down a really bad path and
you find yourself frequenting
fetish orgies and bath houses
wouldn't you like to know
that huh i'm at risk of contracting this
monkey box virus which in the extreme
forms the harsher forms of the virus can
kill 10 of people or possibly even more
huh maybe i'll avoid the orgies maybe
i'll avoid the bath houses but no you
can't you can't be told to avoid the
oranges in the bath houses that would be
homophobic you you had
medical analysts at yale saying don't
let this turn you sex negative
don't turn away from the orgies and the
bath houses but of course you should
but but if we say that there might be
stigma
people might feel stigma yes that's good
stigma is good
stigma can be a very good thing this
this u.n aids agency says stigma can
undermine public health efforts no no
stigma can greatly help public health
efforts we want to stigmatize dangerous
disordered unhealthy bad behavior
society society used to stigmatize all
that stuff
and used to encourage all the good stuff
and the healthy stuff and we had a much
healthier society back then now we've
completely flipped it now normal healthy
good behaviors are stigmatized
starting family getting married
relatively young working hard
having children that's all been
stigmatized you are a pariah if you
engage in ordinary normal traditional
activities
and what is incentivized and encouraged
is all this sort sort of weirdness that
has given us monkey box
so we could use a little bit more stigma
if if the un just came out tomorrow and
said hey all of this mumbo jumbo word
salad that we're sending around about
the monkey pox it boils down to this
don't go to gay orgies and avoid
vacationing in zaire
if they just said that because this is
zaire is largely where monkey pox has
been spreading for the last 40 50 years
if they just said that
you would probably greatly reduce the
spread
of monkey bucks but they're not going to
do it
the the un and the public health
authorities which for the past two years
have been as absolutely invasive and
overbearing as they could possibly be
don't hug your grandparents put a mask
on your 16 month old don't show up to
christmas they've just gone every in any
way they can they've invaded your life
now all of a sudden that the issue is
gay bath houses they say oh well now
listen who are we to judge who are we to
say what you do on your weekends
i thought you were the public health
authorities
i think you can tell people don't go to
gay bath houses
i i think that's okay i think you're
allowed to say that but it's very
politically incorrect these days
in fact the public authorities are
incentivizing all those kinds of
behaviors not just at the united nations
not just in brussels
right here in the u.s of a arizona's
department of education
now has a new plan
to encourage public health among young
people specifically
sexual health among young people
they are proposing chat rooms
for
gay minors so young people who have
questions about their sexuality
to go into and to speak with adults
there are going to be adult moderators
present but specifically
chat rooms that they can hide from their
parents
what could go wrong
when you want to reach people the right
way on the internet you got to check out
constant contact right now go to
constantcontact.com i have worked with
these guys for now i want to say
[Music]
well over 10 years probably more like 12
or 13 years i've worked with constant
contact when i was working on political
campaigns with small businesses
nonprofit
constant contact is a digital marketing
platform helps small businesses and
non-profits of all sizes build grow and
succeed they've got email marketing
contact management industry leading list
growth tools social media ads and more
constant contact helps small businesses
connect with customers find new ones and
sell online all from one easy to use
platform they have been trusted by
millions of businesses to help improve
their marketing they've got a 97
deliverability rate so you can rest
assured that your customers and
potential customers are getting the
right message at the right time they've
got a very simple interface even i can
use it constant contacts platform makes
contact management easier than ever
they've got these great list growth
tools
it means you build a bigger audience
fast generation landing pages text to
join it's just absolutely phenomenal
with thousands of integrations you can
sync constant contacts tools with the
tools you're already using powerful
automation tools i mean that you're
going to get the message out every time
to start your free digital marketing
trial today go to
constantcontact.com
tomorrow i am so pleased once again we
will have the voice mail bag i love the
voicemail bag this is brought to you by
puretalk they are allowing me to respond
to you not just with your written notes
but with your beautiful mellifluous
voice as well so head on over
go to
dailywire.com record your
your voicemail
your voicemail bag in your phone save
the file you can record it on your
computer go to dailywire.com click the
michael knowles show click down into the
mailbag it's going to pop up a little
email you just drop your audio file in
there send it in to me and i will hear
your dulcet tones tomorrow we'll be
right back with a lot more
arizona's department of education now
links to chat rooms on its website for
young people who are identifying as
lgbtq
lmnop plus
to discuss sex and gender
with adult moderators
without their parents knowing
the ade
directed minors to q chat space and
gender spectrum those organizations rely
on adult volunteers and staff to
facilitate the minors talking about sex
in these chat rooms without their
parents knowledge there is no age
verification for those joining the chats
beyond just asking the people for a
birth date
uh we reached out at the daily wire we
reached out to the arizona department of
education about these chat rooms uh no
one has responded to our inquiry the
online chat is so insidious it has a
quick escape function so the arizona
department of education just like old
man herbert and family guy just like
that the creepy neighbor down the street
who's leering at the kids they say hey
come on here are you are you questioning
sexuality young people under the age of
18 will come into our chat rooms yes
they're run by
adult volunteers and
by the way we don't verify anybody's age
in here young people yes come on in and
by the way if you're mean old nasty
parents have a look at you there's a
quick escape button
so if daddy walks into the room and you
don't want them know that we the
government are using his taxpayer
dollars to encourage you to talk about
sex with creepy weird adults strangers
just click that quick escape button
and then it'll disappear daddy will
never see the minute he walks by then
you can come back and talk about sex
with us adults paid for on the taxpayer
time do you think this is a good idea
i don't think it's a good idea you know
what it sounds like to me it sounds like
they're kind of
groomers
you remember a few weeks ago there's
this big controversy how dare you call
the teachers pushing gender theory in
schools groomers that's so unfair that's
what you heard from the left and that's
what you heard from the squishy right
that's unfair that's undignified don't
call them that
no no and you say well it seems like
kind of a slippery slope it seems like a
kind of an easily abused situation if a
teacher is talking about sex to five and
six-year-olds no no that's wrong we'll
never slip down the slippery slow
boom here we are and now we've got the
arizona government encouraging creepy
weirdo adults to talk about sex to kids
without the kids knowing without the
kid's parents knowing
no i'm free i think i'm at the bottom of
the slippery slope but
deep down i know i'm not
i know we're not we keep thinking we've
hit the bottom and we're going to slide
so much further aren't we and and when
when i say that right now the the
liberals are going to say michael you're
crazy you're a conspiracy theorist no no
it's not going to get any worse well i
don't we've been slipping pretty fast
pretty far for a long time now
we're already at the stage of taxpayer
subsidized pervert adults talking to
little kids about sex on government
linked websites
how much further can we go this is why
it's so important for
our legislatures to step up
not the administrative agencies which
are almost entirely unaccountable to the
will of voters voters who are generally
a lot more normal
and a lot more closer to the common
sense than these government bureaucrats
we need to assert our political vision
and our reason and our logic and our our
will through the legislature that's what
indiana just did
so the indiana legislature run by the
republicans
proposed a bill
to ban dudes who pretend to be girls
from competing in girls sports
really basic stuff and we've seen this
throughout the country in lots of
different states
and unfortunately the governor of
indiana eric holcomb vetoed the bill
maybe governor holcomb had his reasons i
like eric holcomb personally actually
i've known eric holcomb for years and i
like him personally i don't know what he
was thinking here he was in the wrong to
veto this bill
so what did the legislature do did they
did they throw up their hands and say
okay
that's that never mind no they overrode
his veto
so
holcomb's argument was in the two cases
with initial rulings thus far far the
courts have enjoined or prohibited laws
with the same substantive provisions
from taking effect based on equal
protection grounds okay so that's just a
way of saying i think the courts are
going to strike down this law because
the courts are going to try to trans the
kids then he also said there was a third
concern
which is that the newly proposed law
implies that the goals of consistency
and fairness in competitive female
sports are not currently being met but
after thorough review i find no evidence
to support either claim even if i
support the overall goal now this this
last part is crazy even if even if he
might have a practical political point
on the first part that the courts could
strike it down again i'm not i wouldn't
bet on that i would i would still
certainly sign the law even if that were
my main concern but this this last point
here is crazy he's saying look there's
no evidence that female sports are are
unfair right now
look at the ncaa women's swimming
championship who won the prize you've
got a giant hulking dude with all of his
giant hulking dude parts
pretty clearly visible in his silly
women's bathing suit that he was wearing
he's got
the gold medal he's got prize number one
and then you've got these diminutive
little girls next to him
they're obviously different they're
obviously at a disadvantage so this
seems to be just a complete denial of of
reality regardless i'm not i don't know
whatever whatever the thinking was in
the governor's office this is the right
thing to do for the legislature to go in
and say look you're our governor you're
our governor and we love you but you're
wrong on this issue and we're going to
override you absolutely the right thing
to do and that's what what conservatives
should be doing around the country when
they meet pushback whether it's because
the republicans are getting too many
calls from worried corporations whether
it's because the governors
are trying to find a middle ground on
this issue of our boys boys or our boys
girls no middle ground to have
whatever the reason
republicans need to stand up and push
back
this will be a political winner i
promise you i promise you it's not just
the right thing to do it's a political
winner
they've said it for years get woke go
broke the woke sexual standards are not
popular just look at old navy
look at what happened to old navy
old navy right now is taking a massive
loss on its company they're angering
lots of customers and why it is being
attributed to their all inclusive sizing
scheme
they've really bought into the body
positivity movement and now analysts
expect the company to report net sales
3.44 billion dollars down from 3.99
billion dollars in the same period last
year that's a major drop
and this these bad numbers are going to
trigger a management shake up what
changed in the last year did the quality
of their clothes drop no it didn't but i
knew this was going to happen one year
ago i was on the subway in new york and
i loved loved taking the subway and i
especially loved looking at the subway
ads and one of the ads was for old navy
and it was a bunch of
big fat ugly people i'm not it's not
even i'm not even saying that big fat
people can't look good or dress nicely
but this this ad was intentionally
making people look grotesque the point
was to subvert standards of beauty and
they said this is a revolution join the
revolution
something to that effect whatever the
copy on the advertisement was the key to
it was this is a revolution in beauty
standards no it's not i just i go to old
navy so that i can buy sweatpants and a
t-shirt i don't go to old navy to engage
in a political revolution but
that was their premise
and they set out to it and they lost a
lot of money as a result it tells you a
couple things
one
it it tells you that
right now
this is not just the radical left
pushing all this craziness that's a
point that i've tried to make to the
right on a number of occasions
capitalism is pushing this stuff too
capitalism is pushing
the revolution everyone wants a
revolution
the left is always pushing for social
revolution in our sexual behaviors in
our traditions in the way we relate to
our country in the way we relate to one
another in the way we relate to our own
human nature and we we revolt even
against our biology
but capitalism wants a revolution too
this is this is creative destruction
this is the idea that we're just
constantly going to be in extreme
intense competition with everybody and
everything old is bad and we're going to
innovate and we're going to renovate and
we're going to get rid of all the old
stuff and build bigger and bigger and
cheaper and faster and plastic and it's
going to be better and better and bigger
and you can get it for even less money
and so that that language of revolution
is always there too this was always
one of the real contradictions on the
american right especially during the 90s
and the 2000s
every gop speech
during the 90s and the 2000s and even
more recently you you get up there and
you say our culture is decaying it's
collapsing it's being ripped apart at
the seams
we need to support traditional standards
and get back to our traditional way of
life and support families and local
communities and all of our traditions
that was the first part of the speech
then the second part of the speech was
and we need creative destruction and we
need to outsource everything and we need
to we need to upend whole communities
and if there's no more job in your
community you've got to move across and
you've got to go work and you've got to
raise gdp and the girls have to go work
and no one should stay at home and raise
the kids and money money money greed is
good
you say wait what happened to the first
part of your speech no no that was just
the first part where i just said a bunch
of stuff to placate the social
conservatives but what i really want is
revolution baby that's what we're doing
and there's always been this tension on
the right
and it's especially become pronounced in
the last 20 or 30 years and what you are
finally seeing you've you've seen the
climax of revolution revolution
revolution
where all of the companies now are even
supporting this revolution against not
just your your nation not just your
local community not just old standards
but but nature itself a revolution
against human biology and sexuality
and the people i think
are getting sick of revolution
i don't think i'm reading too deeply
into the old navy numbers but even take
old navy aside from it the push back
against disney right now the push back
against state farm the pushback of the
parents movement i think people
people can be swept away in the joy of
revolution
you saw this in the french revolution
the most famous
revolution in modernity
people saying gosh it was this
intoxicating time to be young was very
bliss during the time of the french
revolution but as the french revolution
wore on and the terror came and the
absolute chaos and disorder came
people became disillusioned they pushed
back against it you'll notice a lot of
the young prominent romantic figures in
the early days of the french revolution
who loved it so much the ones who didn't
die young the ones who lived long
enough came to detest the french
revolution they became much more
conservative they said i'm done with the
revolution
that is what you're seeing
play out right now among ordinary people
throughout the united states
people are tired
of the revolutions they're tired
of subverted standards of beauty they're
tired of of constantly hearing this talk
of victimhood and the the total absolute
injustice of every aspect of society
that we need to undo libs of tick tock
are great friends who have who have
exposed a lot of this
they have shown
that apparently
the victimhood pyramid does not merely
exist in terms of race you know the the
darker you are the more oppressed you
are it doesn't merely exist in terms of
sex
you know the gayer transer you are the
more obscure your political or your
sexual identity the more oppressed you
are
there are also gradations of victimhood
within fatness
this is the fatness spectrum a small fat
is a size 18 and lower 1x or 2x i'm a
4x5x i'm a size 26 sometimes 28. i am
the super fat you say i'm speaking over
i am the super fat
that you say i'm speaking over so she's
responding to someone on tik tok and
presumably the person on tick tock is
saying don't you dare speak over someone
who is fatter than you
you shut up you because yes you you
might be fat
you might identify as fat
but there's someone who's fatter and so
you need to shut up
and then this girl responds she says no
i'm super duper fat i'm the fattest girl
there ever was so i'm you shut up i get
to speak over you because i'm the really
fat person but you know what
there is going to be someone fatter than
this lady
i promise you i'd bet money on it
go to
some
pacific island somewhere
find some big samoan fella he will be
fatter
now he might rank a little lower because
he's a dude but there will be a big fat
samoan lady and she's going to be bigger
there will are maybe not maybe not
necessarily some
pacific islander but there is someone
there is always someone
who is
more of x y and z than you are
that's the end result of all the
victimhood stuff which is by the way why
the left pushes it because if the
premise is
that
victimhood confers virtue
and only the virtuous should speak and
the less virtuous should shut up and let
the virtuous speak
but virtue we're now redefining in this
totally perverted way to mean victimhood
then there's always going to be someone
who is more victimized
so
the end result of this is not merely
white people shut up men shut up
straight people shut up
the end result is
everybody shut up everybody shut up
except for the one single most oppressed
person in the entire world
we're never going to find that person so
all of you just just to be safe everyone
shut up and let us do what we want
ties right back in with that comment at
the top of the show
the the the conspiracy theories there
are groups of people who are
manipulating public opinion well that's
what we're seeing that is what the world
economic forum is doing right now that's
what they're sitting there they're
saying you are leaders of political
communities i am klaus schwab and you
are leaders of communities
and we will lead we will not let them
make the history we will make the
history
we will and we will we will do it in the
shadows in davos switzerland we will not
let them have any say in it at all
you will just need them and they will
all shut up
nancy pelosi
is finally speaking out against her
bishop who has
barred her from presenting herself for
holy communion
and nancy pelosi has presented herself
as a victim here
speaking of victimhood she has presented
herself as a victim here she's being
unfairly targeted by the bishop who has
the absolute audacity
to
do his job that is that he is called
upon to do to enforce the teachings of
the catholic church for her own good she
says she's really the victim
what's so sad about and as you're
speaking i'm thinking of some of the
discussions i've had with other members
of congress over time and what is
important for women to know and families
to know that this is not just about
terminating a pregnancy so these same
people are against contraception family
planning in vitro fertilization it's
it's a
it's a blanket thing and they use
abortion as the front man for it while
they try to undo so much that's what
they tried to do in the affordable care
act which didn't have anything about
terminating an abortion
a pregnancy so so let's just say that
i you know i wonder about death penalty
which i am opposed to so is the church
but they take no action against people
who may not share their view now our
archbishop has host
vehemently against lgbtq rights too in
fact he led the way in some of the
initiatives on an initiative on the
ballot in california
i'm going to give nancy pelosi the
benefit of the doubt here and say she's
just ignorant about what catholicism is
and she might be she says that the
archbishop he's very anti-lgbtq because
he opposed the redefinition of marriage
as though this were some radical thing
it is
essential catholic teaching the
definition of marriage is essential
non-negotiable catholic teaching all
practicing catholics all people who
believe in the catholic faith and are
practicing the catholic faith
adhere to
the definition of marriage
that marriage is between a man and a
woman the definition of marriage that
christ himself lays out in the gospels
in the gospel of matthew
nancy pelosi might disagree with that
definition of marriage
it doesn't mean that the archbishop is
the radical and she's the normal one
but furthermore
her view
is a refutation
of the catholic view her view is a
rejection of the catholic view
so she can say well and can you believe
this archbishop believes the catholic
thing right what you're saying is i
don't believe the catholic i nancy
pelosi don't believe the catholic view
on this
then she goes on
she says you know i'm against the death
penalty the church is against the death
penalty but they won't do anything about
it she maybe she's just misunderstanding
catholic teaching here the catholic
church does not now and has never taught
that that capital punishment is
intrinsically evil the catholic church
cannot teach that because capital
punishment is defended in the bible
explicitly by saint paul and and by
christ i think you could
deduce and infer but furthermore it's
always been defended throughout the
history of the church as not being
intrinsically evil
the great doctors of the church have
defended it in fact popes have carried
it out blessed pope pius ix carried out
somewhere on the order of 500 executions
in the papal states
was he committing these intrinsically
evil actions no no one would ever
suggest that not even pope francis would
suggest that pope benedict
francis's predecessor put it very well
when he said there can be a legitimate
difference of opinion on the question of
the death penalty among catholics
even john paul ii who really started to
turn
the pastoral practical catholic teaching
on the death penalty in the direction
against the death penalty
he said that it was a prudential matter
he did not it was it was a
cautious wording that that pope john
paul ii used because he knows that he he
can't contradict 2000 years of church
teaching which says that the death
penalty is not intrinsically evil
okay and then the key to what she says
is she goes
these same people are against
contraception and ivf and this that the
other thing
these same people by these same people
she means catholics
yes catholics are against those things
you're right and you nancy pelosi are in
your own words excluding yourself from
that community
you're talking about contraception and
ivf
because you don't want to talk about
abortion because you know that abortion
is indefensible and abortion is a
non-negotiable
unchanged and unchangeable teaching in
the catholic church
but then you are yourself excluding
yourself from the catholic community
you're saying there are the catholics
there are those people those same people
who hold the catholic views and then
there's me right that's the bishop's
point the bishop's point is you are
separating yourself from the catholic
church he didn't separate you from the
church
he didn't borrow you from communion
exactly you yourself
did that
and the bishop for your own good is
acknowledging that and saying you've got
to repent i've got to lead my flock i'm
trying to lead you so that you don't in
the words of saint paul eat your own
damnation if you present yourself for
holy communion in a state of unrepentant
grave mortal sin but but also i'm
protecting my flock because you are
scandalous you're creating scandal for
them
and you're admitted it's your words he
didn't make you say he didn't make you
refer to those same people the catholics
and then me because nancy pelosi is torn
between two religions or at least she's
presenting herself as torn between two
religions catholicism and leftism i
don't think she's really all that torn
though because whenever they come into
conflict she chooses leftism
so that's her religion man cannot serve
two masters
that's hers
speaking of senior citizens new york has
a really creepy plan i have to get to
this before we go because it's so
sad and spooky the new york state office
for the aging
has just told the verge which is a tech
website that they have robots that
they're going to give to senior citizens
to make them less lonely
the robots are leq that's built by this
israeli company called intuition
robotics they're going to distribute 800
of them to senior citizens across the
state and it's basically like a more
advanced version of google home or alexa
and they can make small talk too you can
chat with them so if a senior citizen is
lonely you can chat with the robot and
the senior citizen can pretend it's a
human being
be visited by family members not be
visited by the local community no no
just talk to a robot alone in their home
and once they give these out and test it
out
they're going to start selling them to
people there's a 250 enrollment fee
then there's a 30 a month service charge
to maintain a subscription all to combat
loneliness
maybe people's hearts are in the right
place here i'm not i'm not sure either
way all i know is this is not going to
work
and this is one of the problems
is one of the problems of our society of
the leftism of our society that has
isolated us all from one another and
that has pretended that we're all just
individuals floating in the ether who
have no natural connections to one
another and to such a point that they
defend the right the right quote-unquote
of a mother to kill her own child that's
how little loyalty or connection or
obligation we have to one another
according to them
but it's also it's also a problem of
capitalism where everything has to be
capitalized everything has to be
monetized everything has to be about gdp
andrew yang when he was running for
president he complained he said my wife
doesn't get a paycheck for all the work
she does
why does she need a paycheck she's your
wife
she has a home she has a family she why
did why does she need to get a paycheck
why are we living in a society right now
where people are forced where women have
to go instead of working for her family
where women have to go work for some
other guy so the other guy can pay her
so that she and her husband can pay some
other woman to raise the child that
neither of them have time to raise
so they send the kid to daycare or to
the babysitter the babysitter might have
her own kid so the babysitter will
either have to do exactly the same thing
or rely on grandma and grandpa to watch
the kid well why why does everything
have to be
commoditized and monetized and
capitalized why even loneliness even
community even small talk with someone
it all has to be about the subscription
model it all has to be about just buying
the latest gizmo how about you just go
visit your neighbors how about we have
community
how about how about
but this is of course the issue that
we're talking it ties in with all of the
issues we're talking about today by the
way
the loneliness the isolation the
radicalization
it's not it is it is primarily being
driven by the left i don't want to say
it's well it's just kind of both sides
but it's a it's a really deep
structural issue
it's if you don't believe that something
is going really wrong with society
just look at the old people that we have
completely cast away and sent little
robots in in our place
for it for a fee to go make them feel
less lonely and discarded that's a sick
society i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022
today on the ben shapiro show beto
o'rourke crashes a press conference by
texas governor greg abbott to posture on
gun control senate majority leader chuck
schumer refuses to hold any vote on
legislation and we examine the mass
shooters copious red flags that's today
on the bench bureau show give it a
listen